some successful people  see everyone is a hundred percent  different and so yes maybe three or four  of these things in this article might  work for you but most didn't work for me  I mean the reality is is everybody plays  it different so make sure when you reach  you watch it you always add the word for  some occasionally  maybe for them and take all the [ __ ]  that might work for you and then leave  the stuff that doesn't work that you  don't force things that don't work for  you just because it worked for somebody  else on the flip side  break up your patterns and try [ __ ] try  it before you dismiss it somebody's been  like nah that won't work for me you  haven't [ __ ] tried it so try it  be religious because someone  somebody double you from it sit up try  [ __ ] stay humble and curious  and that's the game